Transcription: Prince Yanel BOKO GOUNOU
Relecteur: eric vautier
Non non non non non non
je ne veux pas y aller.
Bon.
Finalement, puisqu’on y est,
pourquoi pas ?
Des rêves dans les rêves.
J’adore ce concept.
Souvenez-vous enfant quand on vous
demandait ce que vous feriez plus tard.
Toute mon enfance a été baignée
dans les films d’action,
d’arts martiaux ou d’aventure.
J'adorais me prendre pour l'héroïne qui
devait accomplir des missions impossibles.
Je me souviens comme je sautais
et grimpais partout chez moi.
Ma mère aussi s'en souvient.
J'ai d'ailleurs quelques cicatrices qui
me laissent de très beaux souvenirs.
Quand j’étais plus jeune,
je...
je croyais qu’on ne pouvait choisir qu’une
seule passion pour toute une vie entière.
Alors quand on me demandait :
« Sarah, qu’est-ce qui te passionne ? »,
blocage.
En fait, c'était impossible
de choisir pour moi.
Parce que j’ai beaucoup trop de rêves,
d’envies, d’imagination.
Je suis entière et passionnée
depuis le départ.
Je me souviens aussi que Sako,
notre professeur de kung fu,
fait un tour d’élèves dans un réel intérêt
de connaître nos ambitions futures.
Mais dire à voix haute devant tout le
monde ce que je désire faire plus tard,
grosse angoisse.
Et finalement, quand c’est à mon tour,
je réponds du tac au tac :
« Je veux faire comme dans les films. »
Douze ans après,
complètement perdue dans ma vie,
ce rêve réapparaît.
J’intègre une formation de cascadeurs au
Campus Univers Cascades et là, évidence.
Enfin, je me sens dans un bien-être total.
Alors je fonce, je crée mon réseau,
j’intègre mon milieu professionnel
et de là, se dessinent
des idées nouvelles,
dont je vous parlerai un peu plus tard.
C'est là où je veux en venir.
À partir d’un rêve premier,
peuvent se dessiner d’autres rêves
et pour ma part, ils sont arrivés
comme des : « Et pourquoi pas ? »
Une fois le chemin engagé, en action,
les Why not sont pour moi
un panel de possibilités.
Je les imagine comme
des faisceaux lumineux qui entrent
par toutes les fenêtres
d’une maison que l’on a construite.
Voyons plus grand.
Imaginez que vous êtes
la Terre, la Terre Mère
et que les étoiles sont vos opportunités.
Une fois qu’on ouvre une porte,
cela nous donne accès à d’autres portes
et ainsi de suite.
Elles nous permettent de mieux comprendre
si nous sommes ou non sur le bon chemin.
Le nôtre.
Lors de ma première grosse cascade
pour le film « Call of the Dead »,
durant tout un combat, je me fais projeter
dans tous les sens par un humain enragé.
Je ne sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé,
mais ça secoue.
Avant de faire cette cascade,
on me demande d’interpréter un rôle.
J’ai donc une réplique à dire.
Euh... okay...
En fait, c’est là qu’intervient
le Why not, une porte s’ouvre.
Cette phrase m’a mis plus de pression
que la cascade qui a suivi,
qui à elle seule déjà
était un sacré enjeu.
Mais on me fait confiance,
alors j’accepte le challenge.
Et de là, je commence à flirter doucement
avec le métier de comédienne.
Et aujourd’hui, je mesure l’impact
de toutes ces occasions
de jouer des rôles d’action.
Parce que d’une part,
j’adore les interpréter,
et de deux, parce qu’aujourd’hui,
je suis des cours de comédie
pour approfondir et assumer cette porte
que j’ai décidé d’ouvrir en grand.
Les opportunités
peuvent être évidentes par des choix
clairs et assumés depuis le départ.
Okay.
Et il y a celles qui viennent
frapper à la porte.
Celles qu’on n’a pas du tout vu venir.
Elles peuvent être évidentes
pour une tierce personne
qui a le recul nécessaire sur la situation
pour faire émerger cette idée en nous.
Cette évidence peut prendre
toute sa place en soi,
si évidemment,
on la tente dans sa totalité.
En fait, Why not est une liberté
d’expression, une liberté d’être.
C'est s'éveiller sur le fait qu'une
situation n'est pas bonne ou mauvaise,
mais plutôt qu'il existe un mouvement,
une évolution perpétuelle.
Mais attention !
Un échec peut être
un Why not en puissance.
J’ai 18 ans, je suis sélectionnée pour mes
premiers championnats du monde à Toronto
en boxe chinoise.
Opportunité de dingue.
Je suis jeune dans ma façon de combattre.
On m’appelle le rouleau compresseur : peu
importe les coups, je ne fais qu’avancer.
Avec le temps, j’ai appris que c’est
plus judicieux d’esquiver les coups.
Bref.
Premier combat. Premier round,
deuxième round. Boum, K.O.
Je me relève deux secondes après.
J’ai un peu tout oublié.
Je ne sens plus mes jambes.
On est obligé de me porter
pour sortir de la plateforme.
J’ai beaucoup d’émotions
qui sortent à ce moment-là.
Je n'ai pas réussi à atteindre l'objectif
que cette opportunité m'offrait.
De retour à l’entraînement,
ma vision du combat a changé,
mon comportement aussi.
Ce K.O. me permet de rebondir
et de réintégrer dans une autre dynamique
ma place en équipe de France.
En fait, les Why not
représentent des bonus
parce qu’aujourd’hui, ils m’ouvrent
au métier de comédienne,
à l’enseignement, à des séminaires
où je peux m’exprimer sur mon métier
et ma façon d’aborder la vie.
Cela me fait grandir
professionnellement et personnellement,
peu importe l’issue des événements passés.
J’ai remarqué aussi que
plus l’environnement veut
nous maintenir dans une case,
plus les Why not nous permettent
d’en sortir et de ne plus rester ignorant.
Je repense à un épisode.
Je suis dans un moment
de vie pas très glorieux :
peines de cœur, pas de travail.
Je me suis complètement éparpillée
et j’ai vraiment besoin de me recentrer.
Là, comme par hasard, un ami me propose
de le rejoindre sur une session
de saut en parachute.
Je me dis : « Sarah, saisis l’occasion,
c’est le moment d’y aller. »
Okay, on y va. C’est parti !
Je me retrouve dans un avion
à 4 000 mètres d’altitude.
Mon corps, mon cœur, mon esprit me
disent : « Qu’est-ce que tu fais là ? »
Je suis en train de dépasser
mes limites ; c’est l’inconnu total.
Okay, je me mets aux portes de l’avion.
Je suis complètement apeurée,
excitée, en même temps.
Et là, les instructeurs
me donnent le signal.
C’est le moment de se lancer :
je saute, je vole, je vole.
Je ne sais plus comment je m’appelle,
mais je vole. Okay.
j’ouvre mon parachute
et là je suis sous la voile.
Je crie de toutes mes forces : « Ahhhh ! »
Je relâche totalement la pression.
Là, c’est le bruit que fait
le vent dans mes oreilles.
Il me ramène à un calme extérieur,
puis intérieur.
Enfin, je me retrouve
avec moi-même, en confiance.
Ce qui me fait penser,
que le Why not cueilli
participe à une meilleure
connaissance de soi
tout en nous reliant davantage
aux autres et au monde.
Paolo Coelho avait
donc raison quand il dit :
« On ne s’aperçoit pas toujours que l’on
parcourt chaque jour un nouveau chemin. »
C’est beau.
En fait, Why not est une manière d’être.
Et je l’apparente souvent
à une « Yes attitude ».
D’ailleurs, ça me ramène
à une autre question :
est-ce que mon métier a une influence
sur mon développement personnel,
et réciproquement ?
Hum ?
Comme beaucoup d’artistes,
je suis intermittente du spectacle.
Ce rythme de vie est fabuleux
sur différents points de vue,
mais peut être désastreux sur d’autres.
Car il crée des creux d’inactivité
complètement imprévisibles
et j’aimerais mettre le doigt
sur cette zone un peu sombre
qui s’éclaircit avec le temps.
Pour les reconversions professionnelles,
cela doit être similaire,
autant sur l’attente, l’adaptation,
les nouveaux choix de vie etc.
C’est une période de remise en question
qui peut amener une dévalorisation de soi,
une perte de confiance,
la non-rentabilité.
Mais une période de vrai questionnement,
presque nécessaire.
Moi c’est :
« Sarah, as-tu dit quelque
chose qu’il ne fallait pas ?
As-tu bien fait ton travail ?
C’est ta personnalité qui dérange ?
Suis-je faite pour ce métier ?
Est-ce que je vais me retrouver un
autre métier-passion ? » et j’en passe...
C’est une période assez
anxiogène avec soi, c’est vrai.
Mais au fil des expériences,
j’ai appris à gérer cela.
Ne plus être dans l'attente
mais dans l'action.
D’où le « yes » du « why not »
qui me permet d’accueillir
et de transcender ces instants d’angoisse.
Et du coup, je peux répondre
à différentes propositions culturelles,
artistiques, expérimentales,
à l'inattendu.
Un peu comme une errance constructive.
Être à l’écoute.
Accueillir juste le fait d’être.
Vivre sans être dans un
remplissage systématique.
C’est un lâcher-prise qui laisse place à
l’écoute de soi ainsi qu’à l’intuition.
Accueillir ces temps d’observation,
reconnaître les émotions ressenties
et saisir l’énergie
pour repasser à l’action.
D’ailleurs,
dans ces moments d’observation,
les autres sont un fabuleux miroir qui
nous permettent de mieux nous connaître.
J’ai testé.
Et puis après,
on peut aller là où on veut.
Par exemple, j’adore écrire,
peindre, dessiner.
C’est un moment que je ne réserve
qu’à moi-même, c’est ma bulle.
J'ai aussi eu l'occasion de développer
une association avec deux amis.
Pour le coup, c’est mon ami qui me procure
l’envie de m’investir dans son projet.
Et pas du tout à l’aise avec
l’administratif, je me lance le défi.
En fait, j’ai adoré ça,
tenir un projet de A à Z.
Je suis sortie de ma zone de confort.
J’ai même « côtoyé » la notion
de ne rien faire, c’est vous dire.
Et je suis sûre que vous avez tous
cette petite voix à l’intérieur de vous,
qui essaye de vous murmurer un message.
Ça peut paraître complètement
invraisemblable, on est d’accord,
mais pourquoi pas ?
Moi j’ai ma petite voix qui me disait :
« On part à l’autre bout du monde,
prends ton sac à dos,
tu pars toute seule. »
Bon.
Avec beaucoup de peur, je l’ai fait
et j’en suis ressortie
grandie et plus épanouie.
Il y a un proverbe touareg,
que j’aime beaucoup :
« Aussi loin que nous portent nos pas,
ils nous ramènent toujours à nous-mêmes. »
Alors allons-y,
voyageons à travers nos vies.
Pour finir, je trouve assez drôle cette
expression, « Why not ? Pourquoi pas ? »,
une négation qui ouvre
sur un « Tout est possible ».
Alors n’oublions pas de répondre oui.
Une proposition, un changement,
pourquoi ne pas s’offrir la possibilité
d’être plus honnête envers soi ?
Plus authentique.
Si là, tout de suite,
vous fermez les yeux - allez-y -
et que vous entrez
dans votre espace à rêve,
est-ce que vous arrivez à percevoir
toutes ses étoiles ?
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup. Merci, Merci.
Merci de m’avoir écoutée.
(Applaudissements)